welcome to this video playing grandmas
Amanda goro from Thailand yep this is an
old friend of mine from a teammate if
he's playing he sometimes lets students
play I think on this account so not
quite sure if it's him it looks a bit
like him this opening okay so we have a
modern or pills defense that's not a big
exit bit big expert of course
not sure 96 so maybe we can go d5 now KD
father can I can just retreat until this
advanced and redeem help white so much
I actually had thought that maybe d phi
f is an idea
d 5 a night night to your fourth of the
night met but you can probably just take
okay keep it simple plate you five
this shouldn't check shouldn't be a big
big issue for black so night to d4 or
yeah night if I how this is the only
idea that white has but it is an idea we
came not be five also so I guy cover
that prevent prevent night to be five
95 i connect I can I think just taken
play night before so it's not an idea
even
night before
yeah this is a bit weird how to how to
cover now
so should I am yeah maybe I should allow
him to take because I can then go
kicking to gc8 and rock the eight
quickly install this issue of the
hanging um I pawn rook to you one that's
not a Jew needs trick okay easy easy to
see admittedly okay so i can now go here
the only thing that's not it's not so
clear if it is good because um I have
some I have some problem with the snide
ask a lot to cannot really a move but
maybe Bishop f8 I know I don't like it
yeah that's just retreat it's not a good
square on c6 but um I have one a porn
already so
yeah one to get 96 and he tries Bishop
to g4 activating yeah understandable
still the night is good only six Bishop
g4 who creator he can he can take it but
it still it's so just just a pawn down
with the not much compensation so I
cannot go bishop fa to see five
getting the King back to e7 this is just
at least only seven that cavity six yeah
he's trying for nye 2nite to c5 need to
prevent that
who came takes
now allowed far too much activity him
but I hope it's still it's still okay
who came at least the rocks off
and I'm not carried down on the clock so
much
young the bishop on AJ this just bad I
need to somehow get it get it exchanged
yeah I allowed a lot too much activity
and it's not clear anymore that this
should be enough to win the game yeah
exactly like that takes Bishop takes I
can take you three yeah but this is the
draw opposite colored bishops
check it should be a draw at least I'm
quite active but still it should be a
draw
mmm there's some way to at least pose
some problems maybe if i get to get
around to the polls but it's um it's
nothing
to e 1
try to tire the King to the spawn on c3
then then try to use the jeep on
you
now I'll be three there's another target
but it's not really helping we should a
form
see 6m would be trapped the bishop
check time warning rocket is just a draw
grande Ron yeah nothing i can do him he
just always text the b5 the c6 bond and
just exchanges everything off it's a
it's a dead draw before him you can you
can sort of try but it's a it's it's
just it's just not much not not enough
to win the game yeah I probably spoiled
it much before allowed far too much
activity by losing too much time maybe
around here yeah here here I h5m this is
a good idea intending bishop age 6 very
strong this is a computer yeah those
bloody thinks know a bit of chess yeah
and they're not really know of the
calculate but yeah this is a good idea
this this is not this is this is already
a half minutes he got see God's g g5
vision before activating his passive pc
on f3 and while black is still better
it's it's getting tricky of course i
could have played it better even after
that but this is so a very instructive
move also g45 Bishop g4 activating the
bad piece okay thanks for watching